Democratic congresswoman Rasheeda Talib
who openly campaigns for the destruction
of the State of Israel is refused entry
into Israel at which point she begs
Israel to let her in to see her Arab
grandmother at which point Israel offers
to let her come in at which point to
leave says she doesn't want to go we
will examine what congresswoman Talib
finds so objectionable about Israel
spoiler alert it's all the Jews then
President Trump proposes buying
Greenland the mainstream media laughs
but it's actually one of trumps best
ideas yet Planned Parenthood threatens
to defund itself a witness corroborates
a bartender's account of being sexually
harassed by Don Lemon and the New York
Times has a bold new strategy for
covering president Trump and
conservatives they're going to call us
all racist we will examine America's
original sin from the very beginning all
that and more on Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a lot to get to today guys on this my
400th episode I didn't think Ben was
going to let me get to four episodes but
we've managed to get to 400 so thank all
of you who have been downloading it and
subscribing and leaving five star
reviews for helping us get this far I
appreciate it
today's show is gonna be all about sin
specifically America's original sin but
let's start with a more immediate sin
first actually great news with regard to
this sin the sin is abortion and the
great news is that Planned Parenthood is
being defunded at least partially
Planned Parenthood we're gonna get final
word on this today but it looks as
though Planned Parenthood is going to be
defunded and the funnier part is it's
going to be defunded by Planned
Parenthood plant it's not gonna be
Congress it's not even gonna be really
technically the White House it's gonna
be Planned Parenthood that is defunding
itself now that will be to the tune of
about sixty million dollars maybe a
little bit more Planned Parenthood gets
half a billion dollars each year in
taxpayer funding so it's not the whole
thing but it's a pretty good dent how is
this happening this is all because of a
trump administration rule change to the
title 10 program and it tells you a lot
about the way the President Trump does
business and how he does government
because this was a pretty brilliant move
that a lot of us didn't see coming
what is title 10 title 10 is the federal
program dedicated to providing
individuals with comprehensive family
planning and related preventative health
services now family planning has become
a euphemism to mean killing babies but
it doesn't have to be that way it can
also involve birth control or prenatal
care or fail all of these aspects
related to sexual health and to
pregnancy now though Planned Parenthood
just uses family planning to be a
euphemism for planning to get rid of
your family by killing your babies
through reproductive health which is
actually a service to stop reproduction
there's a lot of politically correct
irony and inversion going on title 10
was established by President Nixon in
1970 and now in recent years it's just
been used by Planned Parenthood as a
slush fund so that you at the
taxpayer can pay for abortions even
though legally you're not supposed to be
forced to pay for abortions
so the Trump administration very quietly
very sneakily established a new rule the
new rule bars taxpayer-funded Family
Planning clinics from talking with their
patients about abortion or referring
them to abortion providers so they're
saying okay look we have all this
federal money that's going toward family
planning you can get the money no big
deal
Planned Parenthood you're welcome to the
money only thing is you can't talk about
abortion but that's okay Planned
Parenthood right because Planned
Parenthood always talks about how they
barely do any abortions but abortions a
tiny tiny percentage of their business
97% of services they say are not
abortion related now we know that that's
BS we know that Planned Parenthood only
exists to perform abortions and that
makes up the actual lion's share of
their business the vast vast majority of
it but they cook the numbers and they
try to pretend otherwise so the federal
government says okay fine good you're a
good good thing if abortions only three
percent of your business then it's no
big deal don't talk about abortion and
you get the money but Planned Parenthood
can't do that cuz all they exist to do
is perform abortions so Planned
Parenthood has been fighting this rule
change for months now and we've now seen
two Court decisions rule in favor of the
Trump administration and against Planned
Parenthood what's even crazier about
this is the decisions came from the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals Ninth Circuit
is that very liberal left-wing circuit
the one that Trump himself is called out
and said that that's awful and it's very
left-wing where they always come to
these left-wing decisions and yet twice
they rule in favor of Trump and against
Planned Parenthood even more than that
the court denied Planned Parenthood's
repeal a request rather for an on Bank
hearing meaning all of the judges not
just a panel of judges and they did it
unanimously that is pretty brutal for
Planned Parenthood you've got the most
left-wing court in the land
ruling unanimously against you so
they're not going to bring it up to the
Supreme Court there's not a chance if
they can't win at the Ninth Circuit and
if they lose
unanimously they're certainly not going
to take it all the way up to the Supreme
Court this shows us an incredible
pattern emerging with President Trump
that I don't think anyone is noticing
but it tells you a lot about the way
that he conducts politics we'll get to
that in a second but first I have got to
save you money let me save you money let
me help you out it is impossible to know
what you are paying for with your big
cellphone plan it's impossible to know
because they've all have all these tiny
hidden fees that actually aren't very
tiny when you add them all up right so
you agree to a plan but sign on let's
say it's 50 bucks then you get the bill
it's over a hundred bucks how does that
happen
I don't know but it's always happened to
me with my cell phone plans no more
because of mint mobile mint Mobile
provides the same exact premium network
coverage that you were used to at a
fraction of the cost how is this
possible it sounds too good to be true
right I thought it was too good to be
true it's not mint mobile makes it easy
to cut your wireless bill down to just
15 bucks a month and the way that they
do it is by not selling you a bunch of
nonsense that you don't need every plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talk and
text you get all of that with mint
mobile though what you stop doing is
paying for unlimited data that you never
use between your office between places
that you go to you know movie theaters
or hotels or whatever and between your
home you're not using that much data
you're usually on Wi-Fi but what built
big cellphone companies do is they sell
you unlimited data that you're never
going to even come close to using and
then they charge you 3 X 4 X 5 X which
you should be paying for your plans so
with mint mobile you get plans but
either 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data you use your own phone with any
mint mobile plan you keep your same
phone number along with all your
existing contacts ditch your old
wireless bill start saving a lot of
money with mint mobile you can get your
new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month that's not that's not just a joke
I know you think it's a joke cuz it's so
much cheaper it's unbelievable you'll
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mint mobile comm slash Knolls
Canada wles mint mobile comm slash
Knowles Canada wles cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month that is a
real number that is not a pretend number
go to
mint mobile comm slash Knowles canna
wles
what this tells us about Trump the fact
that he sort of secretly defunded a good
amount of Planned Parenthood
we'll find out if Planned Parenthood
formally pulls out of title 10 today I
mean it's probably happening right now
but it most people are predicting that
they will because they can't go on is
the abortion mill that they are if they
agree to these this new rule that means
President Trump just well everyone was
looking over here while everyone was
looking at all the tweets and all the
coffe if a president Trump accomplished
a significant portion of a significant
promise of something that conservatives
have been trying to do for decades we're
seeing this pattern in 2017 President
Trump
failed to repeal Obamacare do you
remember that he campaigned on Obamacare
forget him Republicans had been
campaigning against Obamacare since 2009
and they just had failed to do a 2010
they didn't do a 2012 then do it 2014
they didn't do it 2016 Trump gets
elected he campaigns on it 2017 they
failed to defund Obamacare to overturn
and repeal Obamacare and that's mostly
because John McCain changed his mind at
the last minute and really messed us
over on an important campaign promise
for the American people but then what
happened
Trump was upset about that he still you
know can't even hear the name John
McCain without shivers going up his
spine but in 2018 the following year
president Trump passed a tax bill tax
bow was good at lowered rates save
people money on their taxes and what
people weren't reporting at the time is
that the tax bill repealed the
individual mandate which was the heart
and soul of Obamacare the whole problem
of Obama well there are a lot of
problems with Obamacare but the central
problem is that it forced you to
purchase a product from a private
company that you maybe don't want to
purchase that a lot of Americans didn't
want to purchase totally crooked totally
unconstitutional and that Trump tax bill
got rid of the Obamacare mandate without
anybody noticing because we were all
paying attention to the taxes we were
all paying attention of the crazy tweets
we were all paying attention to the
cough fa meanwhile President Trump
fulfilled
a good percentage of an important
promise that no one else had been able
to fulfill he did it well we all weren't
paying attention it's the same thing
here you know Trump gets elected in 2016
he becomes president in 2017 and so 2017
2018 up through 2019 he had failed to
defund Planned Parenthood now is that
his fault I guess he could have leaned
more on the house in the Senate when we
still had the house and and obviously
controlled both branches or both houses
of the legislature but it's also on the
legislators what happened why didn't
Mitch McConnell bring this up
why didn't pull Ryan at the time bring
this up because Republican lawmakers are
total cowards when it comes to Planned
Parenthood they don't really want to
defund it there's a ton of squishes
among Republicans they don't they want
to make lisa murkowski or susan collins
vote on that and frankly they like to
keep the pro-life issue available they
like to keep Planned Parenthood being
funded because it's a good fundraiser
from us conservatives us pro-lifers the
minute that you get rid of abortion
conservatives and Republicans lose a
great fundraising tool which is keeping
all of us pro-lifers eager to defund
these abortion mills so I think
cynically they moved not to do it and so
what does President Trump do he doesn't
get it through the normal way the way
that we were all expecting him to and so
now 2019 well into his first term he
changes this rule at title 10 maybe he
didn't even know that they were changing
this rule maybe he just appointed good
people who were able to fulfill that
campaign promise I mean that's what
presidents drew do is they delegate and
one way or another this rule gets
changed and what you're looking at today
is the possible defunding of Planned
Parenthood by Planned Parenthood's own
hand this actually gives credence to the
idea the president Trump is a deal maker
that he does the art of the deal but he
does negotiate that he does get things
done he doesn't do it in the way that we
all expect because we are used to that
typical Republican they know how to talk
they know the phrases we know what the
phrase means when they say they're gonna
move the embassy in Isreal to Jerusalem
they don't really mean that but it does
mean that they'll do this and it means
that and you've got to play like seven
DHS just to figure out what these people
are even saying because they won't
can play in English and Trump comes in
and he actually does manage to keep a
lot of his promises I don't know if it's
most but more promises than his
predecessors at least and he does it in
ways that we don't expect of course the
way to defund Planned Parenthood is to
go through Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
well that hasn't worked so maybe while
we're all looking over here they're
gonna change a rule in title 10 maybe
that doesn't get us half a billion
dollars defunded from Planned Parenthood
but if it if we start with 60 million
that's a good start and if we establish
the precedent that Planned Parenthood
has to give up its abortions or give up
all that money maybe that's a good start
maybe that's a compromise maybe that's
not what we're used to in politics but
it is unbelievably I mean too many
people who thought that President Trump
was a fraud he's a fake conservative
he's a fake deal maker he's a game show
host
what we're seeing is I think evidence of
the art of the deal speaking of bad
people in our government not just all
those bad people who weren't able to
fulfill their promises let's talk about
some really bad people in our government
like Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar there
this blew up on Friday unfortunately we
didn't have a show then big hubbub
Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar were not
going to be permitted to go to Israel
these anti-israel congresswoman wanted
to go to Israel and then Israel said
that they can't go to Israel and
Rasheeda to leave as a grandmother in in
Israel but they she calls a Palestine
and so it's a big awful mess what's the
long and short the long and short is
Rasheeda to leave in Ilhan Omar still
don't like Jews and Israel still has a
right to defend itself and really
regardless of what you think about
American policy toward Israel or Israeli
policy toward the Arabs and the
contested territories or the Democrats
or the Republicans those two things
remain true it's pretty clear Rasheeda
Talib Anil ha no more don't like Jews
and it's pretty clear to people who
respect the concept of nation-states who
respect the world order that Israel has
a right to defend itself as simple as
that so what happened Rasheeda Talib and
Ilhan Omar half the
odd announced they're gonna go on a trip
to Israel except they didn't call it a
congressional delegation to Israel they
called it a congressional delegation to
Palestine Palestine which is that
country right between Narnia and Wakanda
as you'll recall it's a country that
only exists in fiction there has never
been a nation called Palestine in at any
point in history and there still is no
nation called Palestine but the people
who want to get rid of Israel refer to
this mythical nation called Palestine
because they want to get rid of the
country that is currently where
Palestine is which is Israel the trip
was not just on this sort of I don't
know I guess you could call it academic
question of the nature of the foundation
of the State of Israel and the
contesting the the right of Israel to
exist as a nation we can actually just
look at the people involved here this
trip was sponsored by virulent Lee ante
Jewish people specifically a group
called myth de which has accused Jews of
using the blood of Christian Christians
and the Jewish Passover they published
an American neo-nazi essay called who
rules America the alien grip on our news
and entertainment media must be broken
again I'm not using the term neo-nazi
lightly I'm using it to refer to people
who do describe themselves in that way
and who do look favorably on Nazis and
on fascism and the group this group if
de also celebrates terrorists and
suicide bombers really bad hombres to
use president Trump's phrase this is not
a good faith or good will visit to
Israel from these two women and they're
associated with truly horrific people so
Prime Minister of Israel Bibi Netanyahu
gets on Twitter and he says quote no
country in the world respects America
and the American Congress more than the
State of Israel as a free and vibrant
democracy Israel is open to critics and
criticism with one exception Israeli law
prohibits the entry into Israel of those
who call for and work to impose boycotts
on Israel as do other democracies that
prohibit the entry of people who seek to
harm the country in fact the path in the
past the US did this to an Israeli
member of the Knesset as well as to
other public figures from around the
world Congress women to leave in no more
are leading activists in promoting the
legislation of boycotts
against Israel in the American Congress
only a few days ago we received their
itinerary for their visit in Israel
which revealed that they plan to visit
whose sole objective is to strengthen
the boycott against us and deny Israel's
legitimacy nonetheless if congresswoman
Talib submits a humanitarian request to
visit her relatives the Minister of the
Interior has announced that he will
consider her request on the condition
that she pledges not to act to promote
boycotts against Israel during her visit
pretty measured response a country a
country has a right to exist a country
has a right to keep people out who hate
the country
I understand the argument the argument
was how dare Israel keep out a member of
the US government an elected member of
the US Congress sure but this elected
member of the US Congress is calling for
the destruction of Israel we wouldn't
allow a foreign government official who
calls for the destruction of the US into
our country sometime actually that's not
true sometimes we do because we host the
UN in this country because we're adults
and we allow some of the worst people on
earth who call for the destruction of
America to come to our soil I think
that's a bad idea I don't think we
should do it we should probably knock
down the UN and build Trump condominiums
on the East River but the point is if we
believe that that's true for America
that we shouldn't allow people who want
to hate our country and destroy our
country into our country the same should
be true of Israel so Bibi Netanyahu says
you can come into this country for a
humanitarian visit as long as you don't
call for the destruction of Israel while
you're here and what just to leave say
does she say okay I'm gonna go visit my
grandmother no she says she doesn't want
to go she said quote when I won it gave
the Palestinian people hope that someone
will finally speak the truth about the
inhumane conditions hold on a second I
thought Rasheeda Talib was an American I
thought she was elected to give voice to
her constituents in America in Michigan
now she's saying I I was elected to give
the Palestinian people hope what what
you're not the representative of the
Palestinian people at least you're not
supposed to be it's unbelievable
president Trump gets called a racist for
saying that the members of the squad to
leave Omar AOC and
Ayana Presley or seem foreign they're
representing foreign interests they
should go back to other countries he
gets called a racist for that he gets
called a bigot for that he he did speak
technically and accurately because a lot
of them were in immigrants but they they
say how dare you refer to these women as
foreigners Rashida Tillie was admitting
that she views herself as a foreigner
she says I won when I won it gave the
Palestinian people hope you don't
represent the Palestinian people is
first of all there's no such country as
Palestine but if she's referring to the
Arabs who were in Israel you don't
represent them you're not supposed to at
least you're supposed to represent
Americans she was I can't allow the
State of Israel to take away that light
by humiliating me and used my love for
my C T to bow down to their oppressive
and racist policies now I don't know
what C T means I googled it apparently
CT means grandmother
by the way Rasheeda to leave doesn't
know what CT is either because she was
the word CT to race bate basically to
present herself as a foreigner which she
often does but she actually changed the
way she spelled it as the tweets went on
because apparently the more common
spelling is si TTY and she spelled it s
ity in the first one so she changed the
spelling of it so she she doesn't use
these terms and by the way in America we
speak English so if you want to I don't
when I talk about my italian-american
grandmother wife I don't say like oh yes
the other day I went to New York to go
visit my nan na yeah yeah we I took a
plane to New York and then I set with my
nan na and we went there and we I passed
out I caught a bone add up and then we
had some beats uh even when I use the
words that are borrowed I at least use
the American pronunciation that's what
you do in America but she doesn't do
that in other words though in her in her
tweet she says I love my grandmother or
CT or whatever I love my grandmother but
I hate Jews more at the left ring media
actually tracked down Rasheeda to leaves
grandmother and this video hasn't been
making too many rounds but it's worth
watching we'll get to that in a second
we'll see what this means for the squad
then we'll get to buying Greenland but
first you know we're talking a lot today
about our ancestry or views of our ident
what that means for us I love genealogy
I've been a longtime fan of genealogy
and I've been a longtime fan of ancestry
ancestry.com the ancestry DNA cat I've
been a fan of them for years and years
and years now I get to thank them
because they're a sponsor of the show
and they are terrific if you ever wonder
where your family comes from you can
discover more you can learn about your
story by combining the ancestry DNA test
with billions of historical family
records my relationship with ancestry
goes back pretty pretty far because I
would use ancestry to discover all these
cool things about my own lineage I found
out I descend from four travelers on the
Mayflower one of whom was a pilgrim
found out a couple of my ancestors John
and Simon Knowles fought in the
Revolutionary War one of them traveled
with with George Washington at Valley
Forge spent the winter with him I found
out all these cool things my ancestors
who were in the Civil War you wouldn't
know that in the old days it was so hard
to get these records ancestry makes it
easy then I used ancestry DNA so you
basically spit in little tube you send
it over it gives you much more precise
information geographic details and
clear-cut historical insights and you
can actually even trace your ancestors
journeys over time so you can follow how
and why your family moved from place to
place they are just incredible at this
they've combined the DNA results with
over a hundred million family trees and
billions of records to give you more
insight into your genealogy and origins
super easy to get started and it really
tells you about where you come from it
tells you about this this personal
history not that you're probably not
gonna get in a history book but you you
will learn about yourself where you come
from it's great for a limited time right
now for August 20th so not too long but
for a limited time you can share your
story for a chance to win a dream
vacation to where your ancestors once
lived ancestry wants you to discover the
world through your DNA explore your
heritage your history and connect with
family take your self-discovery to the
next level and explore what makes you
you go to ancestry.com for more details
to win your dream vacation go check it
out right now ancestry.com oh I love
those guys check it out so they track
down Rashida to leave CT in Israel and
here is what
her her grandmother had to say about
President Trump spoiler alert it wasn't
terribly flattering she's obviously not
speaking in English so I will translate
Allah may Allah ruin him I was happy
that Rasheeda was coming everyone was
excited that she was coming for her
grandmother to see her hahaha
so what's interesting about this is the
way that the left-wing organization now
this translates it is may god ruin him
may god ruin trump that's not what she
says when she actually says this may
Allah ruin Trump and they don't
translate it that way what they would
say is well the Christian and Muslim
understanding of God is exactly the same
now that's obviously not true for anyone
who's ever read the Quran or the Bible
or I don't know even done a Wikipedia
search but that's the way that it's
being presented and it's it's uh I mean
if if they had translated this and and
you had this picture of this foreign
national saying may allow ruin the
President of the United States in a
normal country at a normal time that
would that would spark some outrage we
don't we don't like that we don't like
when foreign nationals call for our
president to be ruined by her conception
of God which by the way is a conception
of God that traditionally historically
in the United States has not been one
held by Americans now they translated it
may God ruin him they're trying they're
they're trying to have their cake and
eat it too
on this foreign Rashidah to leave in the
squad or totally American but actually
they're foreign and actually America is
terrible so it's better to be foreign
but being foreign is American it's very
confusing to leave put it all together
she said quote on Twitter my CT is the
original hashtag squad member so now
she's not even just saying we're the
squad she's saying this foreign national
is the original squad member which is
the original point the President Trump
was making when everybody freaked out
where she says the squad originally is
foreign Trump says you know the squad
seems foreign and then everyone calls
Trump a racist including the squad
they can't have it both ways and what
this brings up are major questions of
the nation
Israel's a nation does it have a right
to exist we now have two members of the
US Congress who'd say they don't that
Israel doesn't have a right to exist at
least two it's actually more but
certainly Omar and Talib we have a lot
of people in this country who say the
United States doesn't have a right to
exist as a nation we don't have a right
to enforce our borders we don't have a
right to determine who comes into the
country who uses our services who votes
in our elections who becomes a US
citizen we don't have a right to do that
anymore
that is the question that's being argued
and the way that the squad is currently
arguing it is through this proxy Israel
but their ultimate question the ultimate
end of these concepts is the notion of
the American nation and the 2020 race is
going to be a referendum on that
question as well we'll see which side
wins
speaking of Nations and nationhood and
what makes up a nation president Trump
proposed an idea to expand our own
country by buying Greenland seems like a
little bit of a wacky idea perhaps the
mainstream media has pilloried him for
this and said it's laughable and crazy
and ridiculous actually it's one of the
best ideas he's ever had because to
quote Tony Soprano and others it's a
good idea to buy land because it's the
only thing that God ain't makin any more
of the United States has always done
very well in real estate the Louisiana
Purchase in 1803 doubled the size of the
country I don't think we've ever
regretted that purchase the annexation
of Texas in 1845 the annexation the
bring in of California in 1848 we bought
Alaska from Russia in 1867 that turned
out pretty well for us a lot of good
natural resources up there and it's a
pretty strategic location now Greenland
by the way right now isn't just its own
completely autonomous country it's owned
by Denmark so we'd be purchasing it from
Denmark what does Denmark have a right
to own Greenland Greenland is closer to
us were the superpower it's
strategically very important because
it's in the Arctic it's right off our
coast I don't know it seems great
if this isn't being presented as one of
these crazy ideas that president from
tweeted out while he was eating Cheerios
or something this idea actually has a
long history to it we've been
talking about buying Greenland for years
in 2001 national reviews John Jay Miller
talked about it said that this would be
a great idea that I think the headline
of his article was let's buy Greenland
then in 1946 we actually tried to do it
President Truman tried to buy Greenland
for 100 million dollars in gold bars
they turned that down
apparently Andrew Johnson in the 19th
century considered buying Greenland as
he was buying Alaska
makes a lot of sense you know Media
Matters those just scum of the earth
cackling hyenas over there I was on a
television shows on Martha McCallum show
talking about how it's a good idea to
try to buy Greenland and they lost their
minds about this media matters which
writes about me constantly lose their
mind about this is absolutely ridiculous
I said was it ridiculous when Harry
Truman tried to do it was a ridiculous
land where Johnson looked into it was a
ridiculous and we bought a ton of other
land to grow our country why is that
ridiculous and they couldn't say
anything because so they actually they
responded they said we don't know who
you are
Media Matters published a giant piece
trying to make me lose my job a couple
weeks ago and so I reminded them I said
oh I'm the guy that you write about for
a living and the media matters but
that's what they do Media Matters is a
leftist operation that only exists to
get conservatives fired from their media
jobs and so it's worth calling them out
not just the leftists in the media but
the leftists who try to shut us down
it's worth calling them out because all
they have is innuendo all they have is
insinuation they say Oh what uh yeah
that's a good idea
sure yeah by Greenland that's a good
idea I think it actually it's got a lot
of historical precedent to it we've been
trying to buy it for 70 years why is it
a good idea if predictions on global
warming ever do come to pass then as
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo pointed
out this could open up new trade routes
it could reduce the time it takes to
ship goods from the u.s. to Asia by like
20 days it you could open up trade
routes through the Arctic it could make
Greenland crucial and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said steady reductions in
sea ice are opening new passageways and
opportunities for trade arctic sea lanes
could become the 21st century Suez in
Panama canal's I think it's a good idea
mark said they're not interested in
selling it's something that the Trump
administration could pursue and as he
often does he accomplishes policy goals
in uncommon ways you don't expect Obama
or bush or Clinton or Bush to purchase
whole gigantic land masses but you know
look we're in the Trump era we're
through the looking glass maybe it's not
such a bad idea we have got to get to
new allegations against Don Lemon and
why CNN is a hack outlet but then most
importantly we've got to get to why the
New York Times is a hack outlet because
they have a new idea a new strategy to
attack Trump and conservatives which is
to call us all racists I know they've
never done this before it's gonna be so
fascinating to see how that works but
they were going after America they're
saying America is rotten and racist to
the core and we're gonna cut ripken
correct the historical record but first
I gotta say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube
you know we've got daily wire live the
backstage show live on the road at the
terrorist theater in Long Beach coming
up on Wednesday if there are still
tickets available go get them now it's
gonna be a ton of fun go to daily
wire.com you know you get everything my
show Ben's show Drew's show Matt Walsh's
show ask questions in the mailbag coming
up on Thursday you get all of that and
you get the left is tears tumblr you're
gonna need it now more than ever go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back
so President Trump has called out the
fake news media again and again and
again he pointed out that we go too easy
on these guys you know they jump on us
anything we do I mentioned Media Matters
a lot because they just exist to pounce
on whatever conservatives ever say and
get us to lose our jobs and
conservatives don't do that back to them
we don't even have an organization that
does that
so last week news came out that Don
Lemon is being accused of sexual assault
at a bar that just happens to be one of
my favorite bars in New York it's in
Long Island in Sag Harbor and I said
look conservatives should give it to
Democrats as good as we get it from
Democrats conservatives should give it
to the left as good as we get it and
when the left starts offering us grace
three times in a row then we can offer
grace to the left but on the point
itself you just don't know if these
allegations are true now we're getting
more information it looks like this
allegation against Don Lemon might be
true he's alleged to have been at this
bar at Murph's one of my favorite bars
good hard drinking spots so people are
definitely having a couple coca-cola's
over there and some guy goes up to him
and says hey you're Don Lemon can I buy
you a drink and he's like now I'm
actually hanging out with my friends
then later on in the night when
everybody is plastered Don Lemon walks
up to him and allegedly asks the guy if
he's sexually attracted to him reaches
into his own pants touches himself and
then puts it in the guy's face and now
the guy is suing Don Lemon
George goon Ellis who was the boss of
the plaintiff at the time came forward
and corroborated the account so he said
yep Dustin that's the plaintiff works
for me as a bartender and we went out
after work one night we were standing
there he said hey it's Don Lemon Murph's
is a place you go to drink after you've
been out drinking as I told you he's
corroborating my story as well we just
gotten off work that's why we ended up
there because we worked in the
restaurant business by the time
everything is done we can only hit up a
late night spot Don Lemon comes around
the corner stands face to face with us
he's saying so you like me is that why
you're bothering me yeah
says nah man I just wanted to say what's
up then according to this guy goon Ellis
that Don Lemon said do you like me is
that why you're bothering me because you
want to f me put his hands down his
pants inside his ford shorts grabbed his
genitals then came out with two fingers
and clipped Dustin's nose up and down
with the two fingers and said do you
like female genitals or male genitals
I'll clean up the language that was
apparently used so he's corroborating it
you got a guy going on the record
talking about that looks like Don Lemon
might be in a little bit of trouble
lemon apparently allegedly offered to
settle for a couple hundred thousand
dollars some amount under a million
dollars the guy said now you're gonna
give me more money than that and so now
this is going going into a lawsuit I
don't even say this to go after Don
Lemon I don't care about Don Lemon I
don't watch his show I don't care if he
has a show that is only sustained
because in airports the televisions are
on CNN I don't care if he's got the
three viewers who actually watch him
doesn't matter under me
unlike the left I don't care if they
have their own shows but imagine if any
conservative commentator journalist
politician if this had happened to any
of us
you had an allegation like this
corroborated by another eyewitness
imagine there would be calls to take off
our heads there were because to tar and
feather us we would immediately lose our
show immediately lose our advertisers we
would be kicked out of polite company
there would be sexual assault
investigations you would you would be
told that the Republican Party as a rape
problem that the Conservatives have
heard that all the outlets have a rape
problem that's what you hear if any of
that would come against conservatives
and yet the story about Don Lemon has he
been kicked off his show have his
advertisers dropped no of course it's a
total double standard and this is I
think what President Trump was talking
about when he was actually chastising
Sean Hannity for defending chris cuomo
a CNN host in his own little PR scandal
which is they don't defend us they go
for the jugular against us they try to
kill us and we
don't fight back because we believe in
Assam in a civil society we believe in
having a little bit of grace extending
that to us having a little gratitude
having a little humility they don't have
it and so there's nothing moral or
compassion or nice about lying down and
letting the left ruin our culture and
our politics sometimes that means you
have to fight back a little bit hard you
have to fight the lies you have to use
clear language even if it's not pleasant
even if you'd rather not do that and
this brings us to our main question
today the New York Times they've got
this new strategy new strategy same as
the old strategy and that strategy is
they're going to call conservatives and
Republicans and Trump a racist Wow how
novel but they're really turning the
volume up to 11 here there they're not
just saying they have these racist
policies they do this race this sort of
thing they're saying the whole country
is rotten to the core they call it the
16:19 project 16:19 what does that refer
to New York Times tells us in August of
1619 a ship appeared on the horizon near
Point Comfort a coastal port in the
British colony of Virginia it carried
more than 20 enslaved Africans who were
sold to the colonists no aspect of the
country that would be formed here has
been untouched by the years of slavery
that followed on the 400th anniversary
of this fateful moment it is finally
time to tell our whole story truthfully
finally time it's finally time to
acknowledge that America had slavery is
this news 20 but I guess it's news to
the uneducated people who read the New
York Times but it's not news to all the
rest of us we know that there's slavery
America is more honest than any country
in the world about the tragedies of our
history finally time what is this about
what this is about is making this
fundamental argument that America is
terrible you have you have two choices
on the left some leftist politicians say
America is awful
foreign things are good and America is
awful
that's what receded to leave in the
squatter doing but then the left wants
to have their cake and eat it too they
want to claim the mantle and say but we
are the true Americans and the right
they're bad Americans and and it's
actually the most American thing we can
do is
I don't know go to Israel and talk about
how awful Israel is the most American
thing we can do is denigrate our country
the most American thing we can do is
denigrate our American flag and those
are contradictory because the question
you have desk is America good or is
America bad
do we even more basic than that because
history is complicated
do we like America do we not like
America and the left they want to have
both sides of that it seems pretty clear
to me if you're protesting the flag
which is a symbol of the country itself
you don't like America it seems pretty
clear if Colin Kaepernick used to
pretend the flag protest wasn't about
protesting America he said it was about
police brutality but then he protested
the Betsy Ross flag from the late 19th
century so I guess he thought there was
police brutality in the late 18th
century - or so he's protesting the
local police from 1787
I don't doesn't make a lot of sense the
reality is they don't like the country
but sometimes they like to pretend that
they do they should like the country
because their their view of history that
has brought them to hate this country is
just profoundly wrong so the New York
Times explains the purpose of this
project they say the 16:19 project is a
major initiative from The Times
observing the 400th anniversary of the
beginning of American slavery it aims to
reframe the country's history
understanding 16:19 as our true
founding and placing the consequences of
slavery and the contributions of black
Americans at the very center of the
story we tell ourselves about who we are
so they're very honest they say we want
to rewrite American history and we don't
want to say that our founding was in
1776
or 1787 or 1812 or 1620 it's 1619 the
defining essential feature of America is
slavery that's what they want to say now
what they want to pretend is that
Americans have covered up some dark
aspect of our past obviously not we talk
about slavery all the time we talk about
race all the time we've actually argued
about slavery since the very beginning
all right these were debates that it
happened we almost didn't get a
constitution because of debates about
slavery in the there were in the
original draft of the Declaration of
Independence Jefferson wrote about how
awful slavery was how they hated that
the British forced the instr
of slavery on them we've been arguing
about it since the beginning and when
you talk about rough treatment of Native
Americans for instance or systems of
slavery even well before 1619 you see
from the very beginning from Columbus's
voyages there are arguments over slavery
human dignity the treatment of the
natives Bartolome de las casas writes
about this one of the great admirers of
Christopher Columbus but he defends the
natives against this treatment and this
slavery we fought a bloody civil war in
America that killed 700,000 Americans or
there abouts to resolve the question of
slavery we concluded the slavery's
contrary to our national soul we got rid
of slavery now the New York Times and
the left are telling us that slavery is
essential to the American soul here's
the first piece they're running all
these absolutely awful just tripe essays
about how awful America is here's one of
them here's is the big one that's been
going around our democracy's founding
ideals were false when they were written
black Americans have fought to make them
true this is an T historical
race-baiting drivel it's written by a
woman named Nicole Hannah Jones who has
lived as privileged to life as they get
in the United States she's a she's a
former MacArthur Fellow that's the
genius grant where you get half a
million dollars just for how you write
she's won the National Magazine Award a
Peabody Award in a George Polk award and
what's funny is the entire thesis of
this article is that white people are
terrible America is terrible and only
black people have been good in America
and when what's funny is she had been
lists all of her awards and and
fellowships including the MacArthur one
she names a whole lot of white people
who are in those lists and she names a
whole lot of American institutions that
have helped her she's lived an American
dream by becoming a very successful
person in a country that she says is
hopelessly terrible and bigoted and
racist listen to what she says that's
quote my dad always flew an American
flag in our front yard our corner a lot
which had been redlined by the federal
government was along the river that
divided the black side from the white
side of our Iowa town at the edge of our
lawn high in an aluminum pole soared the
flag which my dad would soon would
replace as soon as it showed the
slightest tatter
like all the black men and women in my
family he believed in hard work but like
all the black men and women
my family no matter how hard he worked
he never got ahead so when I was young
that flag outside our home never made
sense to me I didn't understand his
patriotism it deeply embarrassed me now
why is that why did her father have this
sense despite it do you think her father
was an idiot I don't think so I think he
he obviously we've hired this woman who
has achieved quite a lot in writing and
journalism she's thought about these
things I don't think he was an idiot I
think he knew that there were challenges
he was overcoming challenges yet he
still loved his country and in some ways
the country was improving for him and
that was a good thing he was fighting
for because he believed in America so
where did she get this awful
anti-american view well she tells us
because I had been taught in school
through cultural osmosis that the flag
wasn't really ours that our history
meaning ours many black people that our
history as a people began with
enslavement and that we had contributed
a little to this great nation so she had
been taught by leftist indoctrination in
schools that America was awfully black
people didn't have a connection to it
now she she eventually comes to the
conclusion that her father knew more
than she did that there actually was a
reason to like the country but her
conclusion remains nevertheless limited
ultimately wrong and her conclusion
basically is that the only good thing
that ever happened to America was black
people and black people never got
anything from America and America is
still a rotten place but at least there
are black people to help America now
nobody says black people haven't
contributed quite a lot to America of
course that's what we all but we believe
we've all contributed something to
America this is a wonderful place
everyone's gone through hardships and
struggles immigrant groups have gone
through hardships and struggles the
settlers obviously went through
hardships and struggles and we've done
it we've worked it out there's a country
that we love that's not her conclusion
her conclusion is essentially race
hustling anti history she writes the
nation the United States is a nation
founded on both an ideal and a lie is a
lie of of Liberty this lie that gives us
our love of country that's not a lie
it's it was a political tradition that
at that time was not extended to
everyone in the country like it like it
wasn't extended to everyone in the
country anywhere in the world but she
goes without the idealistic strenuous
and patriotic efforts of black Americans
or democracy today would most likely
look very different well of course
that's true it might not be a democracy
at all actually we're not a democracy
were a republic which as we see within
the corrections to this article it
becomes abundantly clear that the New
York Times generally doesn't know very
much about our own country and its
history the very first person to die for
this country the American Revolution was
a black man who himself was not free
this is true this is there are also
strange historical coincidences though
that an iron is I guess that complicate
the historical record there's this
incredible irony which obviously
American slavery develops into this
pretty hardline racial system at least
by the end of it in the early days
though the first legally recognized
owner of a slave for life in what would
become the American slave system was a
black man the slave was black and he
himself was black that's a strange
historical irony we also know that in
Native Americans of the Five Civilized
tribes owned black slaves at a rate
similar and comparable to the
neighboring whites we know that Native
Americans marched black slaves down the
Trail of Tears or shift them on boats to
the New Territories this complicates the
historical question and it complicates
ideas such as the original sin of the
nation this is where so but even with
all of this she hasn't gone totally
wrong yet in this article here is where
she goes wrong she was black Americans
fought back alone yet we never fought
only for ourselves
the bloody freedom struggles of the
civil rights movement laid the
foundation for every modern civil rights
struggle black Americans fought back
alone no Abraham Lincoln no 700,000
white Americans dying to fight this
question no heated arguments at the
Constitutional Convention no heated
arguments among people who weren't black
who wanted to limit and reduce the
institution of slavery no bloody Kansas
no bloody history at all it's what what
this boils down to is white people bad
only black people good America is a
terrible place but but we're the most
American
which is good but we're but it's the
same struggle that the left has been
having do they like their country or do
they not like their country it's funny
is in the corrections to the the article
they they actually incorrectly got the
date of the that they wrote incorrectly
the date of the signing of the
Declaration of Independence which is a
pretty important one they also
misspelled the surname of a
Revolutionary War era writer in the
rights view of America everyone has
contributed there has been historical
difficulty there has been tragedy there
have been evil institutions such as the
evil institution of slavery in part
foisted upon us in port embraced by the
by American history we then fought a
bloody civil war to get rid of it that
was a good thing there were wonderful
movements to to make America a better
place around the world in other places
slavery persists even to this day but we
got rid of it and relatively quickly
that's a good thing that something to be
proud of that's something to love about
this country it's a reason to love the
country and yet there's this idea that
America's original sin was slavery it
was a sin that we will never recover
from there's no redemption from that
that's the premise of the entire new
york times 1619 project and you hear a
lot of conservatives refer to slavery
czar original sin it's not it's a sin no
doubt about it
slavery is a sin America's original sin
is not slavery America's original sin is
original sin we have a fallen human
nature we are not going to get to utopia
we are not going to get to paradise on
earth all we can do is join arms
together have some love for each other
have some love for our fellow countrymen
and for our country try to make this
place better well we can it will never
be perfect there is no going back to the
Garden of Eden that is the fundamental
lie that is the fundamental divide
between the right which is trying to
make the best out of what we've got and
is grateful for the things we've been
given and the left which has a utopian
vision of America that looks with their
friends and countrymen with disdain with
absolute hatred of American history
Americans origins and only wants to get
to that perfect paradise which doesn't
exist
that's the option what kind of country
do you want do you want a country at all
that's our show we got more to get to
but we're out of time
head on over to daily wire and I'll see
you tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Noel's show
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Danny D'Amico our audio mixer is
Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup by
Jesuit Elvira production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation